we're saying we're the next playable Tik
Tok uh for gamers so when we uh um
launched ludio we wanted to see how much
engagement one ludio can generate and we
were very surprised to see the numbers
it was in the hundreds hundreds of times
that one user is replaying the same
moment 15 seconds but they're playing
this over and over again because they're
trying to beat their friend they're
trying to optimize how they did that
highlight moment this is very exciting
in a see company welcome to 20-minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get
started 20-minute leaders is a proud
supporter of makeawish Israel and Tech
to peace and is in proud collaboration
with secret cord Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with
[Music]
CTE Asaf gazit welcome to 20-minute
leaders thank you for joining me um I
really appreciate your time I know how
busy you are I'm really excited to talk
about your your journey that of that of
ludio um and talking about the evolution
of content and the evolution of of you
know what what we're experiencing in the
digital world and so thank you again for
for being here and then I'm really
excited to dive deeper so um you know
let's just get started and jump into it
tell me a little bit about yourself
about what you guys are doing and then I
want to go all the way back to how you
got
here first of all thank you for having
me um so yeah a little bit about myself
my name is Assaf I'm CEO and co-founder
of L studio uh we founded this together
I mean my brother uh he's my bigger
brother uh we founded this in early 2022
so about two years ago um and you know
it actually started way back from our
childhood uh we have the privilege of
you know having a passion for what we do
for over 20 years since we were kids uh
we had to move a lot as we were kids so
we found video games as our solution to
just plug in play with our friends it
doesn't matter where we live it's just
you're always with your friends so this
passion started when we were kids and it
stayed until you know uh until today
still have a lot of passion for video
games sometime when we still have some
you know free time during the day we go
to the PlayStation or whatever play um
what what games do you play the most so
I love more uh RPG games uh when I was a
kid was more of a word of Warcraft or
you know uh
some less familiar games like
Rohan um so also you know shoter games
like uh Call of Duty probably like
everyone not Nick here um obviously it
had to stop when I joined the army when
I was 18 so I stopped for five years
give or take my brother was 14 years in
the Army so he stopped for longer time
um but we always had passion one to do
things together like to found a company
together we always talked even when he
was in the Army and I was I released uh
from the Army then we always talked like
what can we do together what can we
innovate and it always circled back to
where we have the most passion and video
games was it's not only about video
games it's about the social connections
it's about social media uh communities
that's like you know if you combining
all of our passions together so you get
Ludo um and that really started yet who
years ago so yeah let's um you know
pause for a moment on this idea of the
you know there's the experience of
playing the actual game and you're in
the story or you're you know you know
you're immersed in this whole world and
trying to get to some objective and I
see in myself how you know I'm I'm not a
big gamer but when I do I find a game
that I like I just go all in and I it's
like I can't do anything else kind of
incredible especially for competitive
people I think that it's um
and but then they talking me about the
social aspect of gaming because you know
you know I'm looking back at the 90s or
2000s a lot of people are saying you
know gaming is not a social experience
you're you know you're you're not you
know go out and play with friends but
now it's a little bit different so what
is the what is the social phenomena here
and what is the gap that you've
identified that is
relevant so first of all on the contrary
it's a very much Social uh world you
know uh uh there's a story of a friend
of mine that he has kids and he he told
me like someday um his kid and their
friend they they met his house and then
after five minutes his friends left so
you know his father just asked him why
do you why do your friends leave after
five minutes like what happened and he
said no no we want to play together we
want to be together so they left to each
one to their homes to connect and play
video games together so it's very much
Social because you are online you are uh
playing it's like playing uh you know
football or soccer outside but it's just
digitally you're playing and the
opportunities are endless you can be
whoever you want to be you can do pretty
much whatever you want to do um
creativity there is much more um
challenging you know than just physical
things that we're doing so one I would
say that it's a very much Social um
environment but it's more than that what
very unique about video games comparing
to movies or or or um music you know or
songs it's that when we see a movie we
don't have impact on the content now
when you see uh I just saw Fast and
Furious again when I see this movie I
don't have an impact on the content so I
don't have any reason to share moments
to social media but in gaming you're
impacting the content all the time like
you're
impacting what you're doing every
decision you're doing I decide to go
right or left and I decide to shoot in
that or shoot in this weapon so every
decision you're doing you're basically
creating your own moments uhhuh and
that's why Gamers want to share their
moments like you're sharing your
experiences when you travel right so you
share this to social media that goes the
same for gamers when you experience
something very unique your highlight
moment your magical moment you want to
share this with your friends now social
media made a huge shift uh for uh short
form content we see that on Tik Tok we
see that on YouTube shorts reals pretty
much everywhere because of the attention
span of the younger generation even for
us we have less attention span we don't
want to sit down and watch a three hours
of of a movie or stream so we see and
this is how we consume on social media
this is how we consume today gaming
content it's through short form video
clips of highlights of other players
playing and so I think that you know
you're talking about two two key
um I guess Evolutions one I guess is the
idea of people want to see gaming and
people want to stream um which is I
think what the thesis of twitch was and
how we have emerged into this whole
streaming world but then you're you're
saying but alongside that the world of
media and social media specifically has
evolved to be more short form content
consumer consumer expectation is shifted
from the long form videos of YouTube and
Netflix to the short form experiences of
reals and shorts Etc and I guess this is
sort of the com the combination of the
two that you're then bringing to your
product right it's that with an edge
it's not only about watching something
when you watch something you feel left
outside of the experience and all you
want to do is to be connected that's
like the main purpose of social media is
to be connected with the content creator
your friends that post in this you know
15c moment and ludio gives you the
opportunity to actually play those
moments so that's basically a ludio it's
the evolution of content You Know audio
is for listening video is for watching
but ludio it's like the Next Generation
you can actually play those short
moments highlights of Gamers and you
know it's imers to class you can really
relate with experience those moments and
that's how we believe by the way that's
our vision that's how we believe and
that's how we see discoverability
happening in video games so
discoverability means how do I discover
new games how do I discover new moments
within the games I'm playing how do I
discover new characters new weapons it's
in short form content and frictionlessly
immediately you can just turn from View
mode you're watching something to you're
actually playing whether it's on mobile
PC consoles you know any platform
incredible and so now we're actually
taking the concept of engaging with
content to a different to a different
experience right yeah amazing okay so
walking through the the foundation the
forming and the founding of of Ludo how
how did it how did it start you know
where are you
today sure uh so like I said it started
two years ago um and I got to say it
started
with I wouldn't say that we were you
know it's there's a huge risk as an
Israeli entrepreneurs to found a b2c
company in Israel right mainly B2B here
mainly cyber mainly uh Enterprise
softwares um this is not a bread and
butter of the Israeli uh startup Nation
so uh it was a risk founding a b2c
company uh and also video games or Media
Company it's not our strength here in
Israel and even the gaming space in
Israel it's mainly like casual games so
it's more data driven kind of stup we
don't have an entertainment industry in
Israel uh but actually you know what I
found and what when me R my brother when
we talk two years ago when we found the
company we found that not only it not a
disadvantage that we're not from the
industry we're not you know from the
valley or La we're not X Activision or X
EA this is an opportunity coming from
the Israeli can do Spirit the uh problem
solving mentality The Innovation
mentality of Israel and coming as an
Outsiders to the industry with fresh
eyes that what led us to innovate it's
you know the video games industry it's a
very old IND it's not very old but it's
an industry that's been working pretty
much the same for the past two decades
it's um the same methods of how they are
launching games how they're developing
games um how they're marketing their
games it's pretty much the same and this
is why people from within the
industry they're having harder time to
innovate that's what we felt so there's
an opportunity to come specifically from
Israel which I don't believe that we're
like the startup Nation right there's a
lot of startup Nations Singapore the
valley I think what's really defines
Israel it's more of the um doing the
impossible nation and Ludo you know
playing the um playing the short moments
of someone else it's still doesn't
resonate with people that it's
impossible we're talking with people
from the industry it's you know it's a
first of its kind experience um like
playing the short form content it's the
first of its kind of experience and when
we're talking with people from the
industry they're still thinking it's
impossible until they actually feel the
product and believe that so that's
exactly the advantage of coming with our
mentality from Israel and building this
kind of Innovations in in this
industry incredible were there any you
know any you know now for as an
entrepreneur looking into your into the
thesis that you've come into this world
with and and how you've started
validating this thesis were there things
that surprised do about the gaming
industry that that you thought perhaps
you knew as a gamer or as a consumer but
now all of a sudden as an entrepreneur
you're you're looking at it with
different
eyes yeah so first of all I think that
uh what I really understood that the
video games industry is working pretty
much like the uh the movies Industries
you know like uh Hollywood the
production the whole even I just uh I
was in LA and there was the uh video
games Awards like the Oscars of you know
the video games it's
pretty much the same and although it's
more technological industry Right video
games it's it's technical things and you
would expect that they would uh adopt
Innovation much more easily or even
innovate themselves it's not so true so
it's hard to innovate within that
industry on one hand on the other hand
what we found and was really surprising
is that they are open for new ideas so
although innovation doesn't come a lot
from within and if you think about video
games they're pretty much the same
although yeah the graphics are better
and the experiences are better that's
amazing I'm not taking that away it's
still Innovation but really disrupt
disruptions and disrupting the
industry it's something that it's
um it was surprising for me to see that
the video games are still pretty much
the same um so for us what when we came
to this industry from outside and
Outsiders what I've learned is that you
still need someone from the inside so
our whole Fe the company is we're
keeping the R&D and The Innovation
Center here in Israel and the whole
business part of the uh the company is
going to be in La uh we just hired our
first CMO uh so he is a Activision
PlayStation kunami Brothers you know all
the big guys uh so he worked there he
knows pretty much everyone from the
industry um so all of our marketing be
the customer success departments are in
La you know they know the business they
know the people they know the um how
things are working from within and we're
bringing the tech and the product to
meet the market needs so that was our
solution to bridge that gap between
those two different worlds of video
games and I would say the uh like I said
the doing the impossible nation that
that's that's I love that and I love the
distinction of the impossible nation and
the the sort of the the idea behind
coming and disrupting an industry coming
from the outside but but you're not not
really just from the outside your you
you you really understand the consumers
right H so you really understand the the
users I'm curious from a product
perspective and from a company building
perspective it feels that in the gaming
industry and especially when you combine
gaming and social media a lot of it is
you can see very quickly the engagement
of of of the of the users of the
customers and and get you know real
feedback very different let's say from
the more traditional enterprise software
world of of the of the The Impossible
Nation right and I'm curious how how
have you been you know leveraging it is
Advantage disadvantage what is the
experience been building a company that
is so that you know that is so consumer
facing I guess that you can actually can
very quick you and you mentioned also
the experience of having people that
don't believe don't understand the the
con the the behavior of the product all
of a sudden they see they experience it
and they say okay wow this is possible
how have you as an entrepreneur you know
played with this first of all I got to
say it's very exciting as an
entrepreneur uh one because this is our
passion and everyone pretty much who's
working in Ludo has passion for video
games so it's it's seeing that in the
eyes of the consumers the wow moment
when they understand they can actually
play that and after they're playing this
they can really feel that thrill of
trying you do that better than you
compete with between each other uh we
saw the amount of times that players are
playing Ludo you know we compare that to
Tik Tok right we're like we're saying
we're the next playable Tik Tok uh for
gamers um so on Tik Tok if think about
the engagement you have like you're
watching every uh post for twice three
times two times three times give or take
but so when we uh um launched ludio we
wanted to see how much engagement one
ludio can generate and we were very
surprised to see the numbers it was in
the hundreds hundreds of times that one
user is replaying the same moment 15
seconds but they're playing this over
and over again because they're trying to
beat their friend they're trying to
optimize how they did that highlight
moment um so this is very exciting in a
b2c company I'm going back to your
question it's very exciting because you
see the feedback loop very quickly you
see the um excitement in their eyes of
your of you know your users and you get
the feedback very quickly and you can
iterate that uh very fast to meet their
needs um it's very different than
building a software for B2B companies
much slower I would assume no I'm not
found in a B2B company but I would
assume it's something
different I can I can only imagine I can
only imagine so now you know post series
a the companies growing you know
reflecting back what what has been the
most I guess exciting part for you as an
entrepreneur you know looking back now
at these last few years two years and
I'm sure you know two years is may may
not be a long time in the context of
life but I'm sure that in a startup
world like I've experienced one year of
that you know it's like a whole life
what what what's been you know really
you know either really exciting for you
challenging for
you um so I can go back to one specific
specific event I would say like a a
combinational event every time that know
our thesis of hiring is is at this stage
of the company when we are 40 employees
here in Israel and uh additional five
employees uh out of Israel so our thesis
is when we're at this stage we want to
hire the best people you know the top
experienced people from the industry so
our
management um uh management team has
about 20 25 years experience no each
each
executive and what was really excited to
see that every time we're talking with
someone they're actually coming so these
experienced you know VP uh um data CTO
vph HR CMO all these guys has a lot of
years of experience they could do a lot
of other things besid going to ludio to
a uh b2c startup from Israel but they
decided to come here here they decided
to trust us me and my brother and it's
not only the executives it's all of the
team I think that's the most exciting
part is to the hiring part to see that
those amazing talented people are
actually joining the team and me and my
brother are saying that all the time
like we can't believe that this is our
team we're really excited about this so
it's uh it's an ongoing excitement I
would say I love it Asaf I I really want
to thank you for for for coming on this
is a this was an awesome episode and I'm
really excited to share your journey
with with others um you know both from a
personal perspective but also looking at
it more broadly as an industry and and
it also feels like you you've you
experiened a significant role yourself
within the ecosystem and and what that
means to be a part of um know not just
without the gaming industry but the
entrepreneurial industry but then also
the Israeli ecosystem and I love the
distinction to The Impossible nation and
the way that you're looking at G the the
world of innovation within gaming the
disruptors there while understanding the
intricacies and the importance of having
the you know the people inside but then
also from an entrepreneur perspective um
the the the complexity of the journey
the exciting parts of it but then also
the fulfilling parts of I'm
understanding well I'm building
something that actually people want to
join and to trust us and so I you know
hopefully I captured some of the some of
the moments we talked about where it was
very meaningful episode for me so thank
you very very much for joining MEK you
very much thank
[Music]
you